olá gente é bom
eu prefiro é sempre chamado de lucas é é
desde muito jovem sempre falou que isso
é um grande elogio porque quem faz
diferente é o mais é que mudar o mundo
então é eu trabalho há 40 anos na área
de educação é do instituto nacional
mas é aquilo foi pesando pensando porque
não tinha a ver comigo com a pessoa que
eu era e pesando porque eu não suportava
ver esse tipo de coisa
duas salas de aula tradicional uma do
século passado e uma da atualidade e
francamente gente tem diferença
então é isso foi pesando e eu trabalhei
muito tempo pra mudar essa estrutura mas
o estruturas muito grandes elas são
muito engessadas elas são possíveis e
silvio você estruturar esse tipo de
mudança então já que a estrutura muda e
muda o professor josé dos campos e é bom
ter a uma outra onde chama extinto solo
mi e começou a fingir que astrônomos a
minha ideia era criar uma mudança que
abraçasse mais gente abraço e então eu
trabalhei com garotada de outras
habilidades em situações de risco de de
escolas públicas e outros que têm
recursos que é um grupo menor para
juntar para que todos nós pudéssemos
mudar a situação do mundo
então o que a ong faz é é um grande
impacto social e ela trabalha com
estudantes com crianças e adolescentes
de altas habilidades que tem o perfil de
liderança transformadora são crianças
que vão ser luzes inspiradoras e que vão
ter compromisso mudar o seu entorno
então eles têm todo foi todo o processo
necessário para que a educação em
processo é totalmente fora da caixa
quando a gente olha o ensino tradicional
ele certamente
não trabalho autonomia e não trabalha o
empreendedorismo empreendedorismo se
aprende em terceiro
você enfileirado olhando seis horas por
uma série uma parede verde realmente
isso não é empreendedor
então tem que mudar
você tem que criar outras estruturas que
realmente façam a garotada conseguir se
expandir conseguir se divertir
a primeira o primeiro termômetro quando
a gente desenvolve junto com eles
algumas são é esse o tom é divertido que
eu tô me divertindo o que tá legal
eles vão se divertir eu tento me
divertir todos naquele processo tem que
estar motivados e estimulados tem que
ser muito legal
outra questão e não trabalha a
singularidade de cada um você é igual a
ela você é igual a mim só de sua neta
mil e não emergente é as pessoas têm sua
personalidade sua singularidade elas têm
que ser respeitadas
então essa imagem é muito legal porque
ela deixa muito claro o absurdo de você
querer é passar uma mesma medida em uma
mesma régua para conseguir medir
metrificar diferentes perfis diferentes
e talento não dá
então você tem que criar estruturas que
sejam flexíveis estruturas que sejam que
respeitem a personalidade o que o
estudante é saber se os conectados
pessoal
isso dá uma célula morta isso dá uma
célula viva se intercalando se
conectando é é passando é fluido é é
outra coisa completamente diferente são
duas coisas
então quando você diz conecta os saberes
você perde toda a interligação toda a
conexão você perde muita informação e
você antônio mundo artificial já
aconteceu é da vontade de cima não pode
ser dada já cogitei deixa eu ver alguém
que o ajude o senhor já aconteceu com
você chegar o dia na sala de audiência
porque eu estou estudando isso é você
mesmo
é já aconteceu com você
isso é injusto gente vai fazer num isso
não é justo não porque é porque é
verdade que ainda não sabe que está
estudando uma barbárie timo eu sou
físico eu gosto disso mas não chegou a
jogar e tinha não só para quem está
estudando então é muito justo não tem
cabimento tem que fazer sentido todo
prezado tem significar em que tem que
ter desembocar em alguma coisa que faz
sentido então essas estruturas só não
isso é importante que vai ter na própria
gente esse argumento cai na prova pelo
amor de deus sabe num isso não é
argumento
então gente é todo esse processo está
desgastado demais a educação ela ela não
comenta que um indivíduo se conheço
outro conhecimento tem só sobre o
projeto de vida pessoal chega no
terceiro e no médio e chutasse mãe
mandou eu chutar esse daqui pra fazer
universidade
essa decisão ela tem começar atrás e sem
se conhecer a partir do momento que a
gente entende como pessoa do mundo então
tá faltando muita coisa e é muito mais
coisas só se emocional do que
propriamente competitiva
esse direcionamento das escolas ainda
hoje ainda spessato para vestibular é o
adestramento para resolver questões
isso é um absurdo é você muita sede de
muitos estudantes que entrar na
faculdade depois mudaram diz que estou
fazendo aqui cadê mamãe quem sou eu
não não não é não prepara é você
resolver questões entrar mas entrei pra
que que vai fazer qual é o próximo passo
tudo isso é muito absurdo
tem que ter uma importância do potencial
enorme de mudar o modelo de aprendizagem
mudar o modelo escolar porque a escola
série escola é importante quando a gente
disse
vamos olhar o futuro é o país passa
necessariamente pela educação
a garotada passa roupa o tempo na escola
então tem que ser muito relevante é
muito sério
muito importante é é uma
responsabilidade tremenda
então quando a garotada trabalha conosco
cada insucesso cada insucesso dói na
alma sabe caso de sucesso indicado um
sucesso porque há por que o ser humano é
um sistema complexo nem sempre é preto
no branco então essa dificuldade ela ela
faz com que a escola seja é a prioridade
é seja mais fácil mas ética mas não é o
que tem que ser e isso tem uma metáfora
muito legal que traduzem exatamente a
lógica da escola tradicional ea escola
que a gente está querendo fazer há
escolas que são gaiolas e há escolas que
são as escolas que são gaiolas existem
para que os parceiros desaprendam arte
do vôo pássaros engaiolados são
parceiros o controle em gaia lados o seu
dono pode levá-los onde quiser
pássaros engaiolados sempre têm donos
deixam de ser parceiros porque a
essência do passa o vôo escolas que são
lados não hã pássaros engaiolados o que
elas amam são passos em voo
existem para dar os passos coragem pra
voar ensinou e final vou isso eles não
podem fazer porque eu vou já nasce
dentro do espaço da gente
o vôo não pode ser ensinado só pode ser
encorajado então a escola tem que ser um
espaço de construção conjunta de
motivação de prazer de de oportunidade
então é isso que a gente quer construir
isso que a gente faz dentro da os alunos
mas pode sair um pouquinho lei no
sentido de que tudo que é feito lá
dentro é multiplicado para a comunidade
há dois anos atrás eu comecei um piloto
com 18 estudantes no projeto
esse ano a gente está com 150 ano que
vem são 400 o esse ano com 250
estudantes nós empatamos 10 mil crianças
de escola pública porque essa ela essa é
a contrapartida que todos nós temos para
fazer o mundo melhor
dentro da nossa metodologia não tem não
tem como dissociar gente é você não pode
atender se você não está bem se você não
se conhece não tem assim eu família o eu
profissional o eu e isso tudo é você é
um só que você não tá muito homem mulher
você é um só então essa conexão tem que
ser resgatada
essa conexão tem que ser respeitada
então dentro da metodologia gente
trabalha isso e realmente o que gente
estrutura são oportunidades
a nossa garotada assim como a gente
mistura é a há momentos em que eles
trabalham separados mas não
necessariamente depende do perfil e há
muitas atividades que eles fazem juntos
a partir de 5º 4º ano e sim repente dei
depende do perfil dele e se conectam
como o terceiro aprendiz de feiticeiro
então o que a gente faz é oportunizar
todo tipo de projeto para que ele vá
sentindo degustando e se conhecendo
então é tem tv nós temos a tv cinema
teatro ajudou a e uga os portes mandarim
japonês alemão francês espanhol inglês
a programação se programação de
segurança digital robótica e enfim
aquilo que pintar na cabeça da garotada
e eles quiserem degustar nós vamos atrás
porque assim a escola entende se a
escola isso bem vindo se você gostar bem
a escola é veia eu vou te conhecer
em cima disso e vai estruturar o que é
preciso para você evolui
é assim que tem que ser a escola a
vencer liquida como diz balbino e fluida
e suscetível pode então a gente
oportuniza que vai ver todo tipo de
situação e isso é muito legal porque a
gente respeita à união a garotada as
dinâmicas entre eles e é muito comum por
exemplo equipe segurança digital que tem
um estudante do 6º ano em que é do 8º e
do 9º
o terceiro e eles participam de torneios
universitários e queijo em primeiro
lugar no gauchão super respeitados então
se é legal que tudo que eles desenvolvem
eles que o protagonismo já não importa
não importa se está na regra segunda
regra e desde que só se sentido desde
desde que que seja algo de crescimento
eu vou eu vou trabalhar vou fazer
então ele se permite ser quem ele quer
ser ele se permite crescer e é isso que
a gente busca e buscar alavancar isso
porque ele vai depois de produzir ele
vai exemplificá ele vai inspirar outras
pessoas pra isso aqui mostrou várias
situações existem desde pré escola e é
impressionante gente quando você dá asas
o que sabe quando você dá voz o que eles
fazem eles conseguem
nós recebemos a vice primeiro ministro
da china porque ele está mandarim e a
garotada do fundamental foi recebê lo a
bater um papo abraçou o time e os velhos
amigos assim então eles eles não tem
barreiras eles que constroem de uma
forma muito leve
o grande lance que a gente trabalha
muito com a garotada quem já aprendeu
articular oportunidades e possibilidades
nós em parceria com a universidade local
el conseguimos carreta que transformamos
em laboratório de robótica ea nossa
garotada é vai até a escola pública e se
na robótica pra garotada do público para
a garotada de situação de risco então
ele citou no seu talento ele se doou pra
fazer diferença na vida de outras
pessoas para abrir a oportunidade na
vida de outras pessoas estão desde cedo
eles eles empreendem desde cedo eles com
os pais em sonhos planeja o estudo e
vice se estruturam aqui em escolas
públicas a garotada indo e trabalham
nessa nossa casa tinha que é
compartilhada com muitos parceiros como
a ong a gente tem que ser muito criativo
é para ter os recursos e e aqui dentro
da carreta a garotada trabalhando e
depois a gente faz curso de
aprofundamento vai dar oportunidade a
gente abrir cursos de todas essas coisas
essa garotada tem abrimos para escolas
públicas exatamente também e muitas
vezes eles dão aula para os colegas
então os olímpicos aqueles que fazem e
pizzi que são muito bons em uma
determinada área se reúnem em mostrar
sempre tem tem colaboração também da
gente mas eles se estruturam eles vêm e
se propõe a gente está junto mas aí eles
não olham para os envc crescem
infinitamente porque eles se tornam sabe
parte do mundo ele se torna livre dentro
do mundo estão aqui e se é da dona da
tvi faz filmes para ensinar o bote
programação e outros cursos
então é muito legal como eles vão se
conhecendo desde cedo eles vão se
conhecendo e quando investiu em uma área
quando e se define por um caminho está
muito claro para eles que esse o caminho
naquele momento que faz sentido então
não é dúvida
e quando há dúvidas eles sabem lidar bem
com as dúvidas
então aqui mostra várias situações é
nosso estúdio e nós temos muitos
estudantes que foram meus alunos que
foram do projeto e que estudaram martins
tempo é verde e também aqui em
universidades bacanas e que são mentores
a garotada inspirou a garotada né diz
assim olha vem por aqui que caminha
legal e aí eles vão escolhendo percebeu
que não basta ser né
jogador tem que participar eu lá no meio
do time no ano entendo nada de futebol
então gente nós fazemos muitas parcerias
songs como aqui onde a gente de óculos
nem para pessoas que não têm visão então
é muito bacana porque eles se apropriam
de possibilidades e quais são os
desafios porque não é fácil como ele
falou não é assim que nenhum de nós
nasceu nesse de s
nenhum de nós viveu e aprendi com esse
olhar o primeiro desafio
eu gosto muito dessa frase das linhas
que é não vemos o mundo como ele é
vemos o mundo como o nosso
esse é o desafio porque a escola é muito
mais do que estrutura e recursos a ela
ela se refere a pessoas e quando você
quer mudar uma escola quando pequeno da
educação seguinte muda pessoas que vão
dar perspectivas
esse é o maior desafio que diz assim mas
todo mundo sabe que não está funcionando
não é fácil mudar não é
não é porque você fica uma dúvida entre
o oeste eo anseio da mudança você fica
naquela complexidade eu quero mas eu
tenho medo porque vai ser muito
diferente pode dar errado então você tem
que trabalhar muito a segurança das
pessoas o olhar das pessoas para que
elas 11 para aquelas harris para que
elas tenham coragem para a mudança e
sigo um desafio à construção de uma
identidade compartilhada é para que as
pessoas gastem e luta em vão junto pra
que elas se tem que desenvolver uma
cultura onde todos que é a mesma coisa
que acontece na casa da cidade
então você desenvolve uma cultura de
todos se engajam e vão juntos e aí
funciona então esse é o desafio de você
fazer essa construção
no começo do ano nós temos poucos
espaços
muitas pessoas querendo entrar a gente
faz um processo seletivo consistirá e aí
é uma pra mim é uma série de ações
e tem também a oficina que os próprios
estudantes aplicam naqueles que querem
entrar porque assim eles vão aprendendo
assim a tomar decisões a sensibilidade
do outro de de atuar sobre a vida do
outro
então eu já saio para os pais muito
abertamente olha a flexibilidade sim a
coisa acontece porque você tem que ver
quem tem sinergia com aquilo que você
constrói e se tivesse energia vamos
junto então faça parte dessa cultura e o
terceiro desafio
eu acho que é um desafio que eu me gosto
diariamente que é a mudança da gestão
linear de controle para a outra que seja
mais o poético
porque quando você quer que tudo dê
certo você e você é muito protagonista
começou e logo
ainda é possível você você toma as
rédeas você fazer pega as regras para
coisa acontecer e você tem que se tem
que segurar porque dá chance mesmo que
outro r é uma profecia básica não tem
importância
no final de cada ano toda a garotada e
os pais pintam escola fazem reforma
muito é uma ambos feira do campo mas é
deles
é importante eles estão construídas
aquela noção de pertencimento isso o
custo dessa ótica gente muito mais com
viço empresas mais jovens do que em
escolas empresas jovens têm muito esse
olhar o ex-dono de pertencimento de
cultura de preço muito mais do que
escolas têm então nós convivemos com
muitas empresas parceiras que nem todas
a nossa garotada muito jovens como você
eo legal é que eu tenho visto muito
jovem no princípio da preocupação da
educação isso é muito bacana um jovem
falando sobre a demanda dele o que ele
considera que é essencial dentro de uma
escola que não pode faltar na escola
ideal é a liberdade de expressão que
basicamente ou é muito bom você gosta
que o professor questionar dialogar de
uma maneira um pouco mais descontraída e
também se envolver com a escola fazer
parte dela e colocar projectos as coisas
pra fazer parte dessa negócio não
o início de alguma forma você sempre tão
estarão conectados com a educação se
você tem filhos
então não adianta mesmo que você não
atua diretamente no trabalho
profissionalmente você vai atuar na
educação a partir daí interessa pessoas
crianças então a educação é importante
para todos os nossos não tem como
escapar
a escola tem feito de verdade e
liberdade e da autonomia para você odeia
frente no que você quer você se destacar
onde você gosta e mesmo assim a
liberdade dada a responsabilidade pra
você então se fixe amiga com
responsabilidade
enquanto você aproveita sua liberdade
então pra mim que vocês é uma escola de
verdade
então gente é isso nossa garotada buscas
ele que busca fazer a diferença dentro
de cada um da sua área da sua
competência
quando ele falou que o trabalho com
altas habilidades
todos nós temos habilidades é que a
garotada com a qual o trabalho aqui um
ritmo muito mais acelerado
muitas vezes o pessoal tem que ter um
ritmo acelerado a vantagem é boa
vantagem que todo mundo feliz valeu
mas quando a criança tem esse ritmo ela
tem mais angústias ela mais precoce
então é muito importante que ela
rapidamente têm esse esse espaço para
construir para se produzir e que com
isso também mudou o mundo
jack é uma dica tá é preciso ter coragem
de ser diferente é preciso não é fácil
ser diferente quando você é diferente
quando você faz diferente você é virar
de alguma forma
sabe uma charge para que os outros acham
engraçado de jogo de luta não é fácil
ser diferente mas é importante você ter
competência para fazer a diferença
então é isso que a gente tenta fazer e
eu estou muito feliz de ter sido
convidado aqui e que eu posso
compartilhar minha estrutura e o que a
gente faz com vocês
obrigada gente vai cuidar